no no wait wait dude okay you're scaring
me III didn't want to tell you when we
were in here all right I was going to
tell you today I got accepted to an
artist residency program in Boulder
Colorado and I'm gonna go I was gonna
sell my and use this as an
opportunity to move me need to get you
into therapy
today this is an emergency okay okay
fun fact Oh Alana did you know that you
could fly to Boulder a connecting flight
through O'Hare with a layover in
Pittsburgh for $42 I mean I have never
looked up how to fly to Boulder this is
a Google what is Boulder no you didn't
even tell me you were playing do you not
consider me someone to talk through
with are we not partners in that way
of course I do wanna you're my only
friend
well I guess you've been stuck with me
for a while but not anymore
oh dude no I I don't feel that way I
wanna wait just wait
oh-oh wanna vulva you have ruined the
best part of this interactive production
for me not now
I'm sorry dude I'm sorry I feel really
stuck in my life right now okay no
nothin I need a change this is just like
you with grad school I mean you're
settling into a track and figuring out
your career yeah but I picked a school
in New York I factored you in I always
factor you in otherwise I would have
talked to you about it
I know I know I'm sorry
well does anybody else know I mean I
just talked to my mom and your mom just
told my mom that is so fighting to me
hold on Ilana
I will not come up I can not believe
that you would not tell me this if
there was even a chance of you going
dude I was scared
I mean I'm still scared do you think
that I want to leave you know I almost
wish I didn't even get in so I wouldn't
have to do this
hahaha like you're not gonna get in to
some art program you apply to you are
the best artists in the world of all
time no I got it are you kidding me no
I'm not I need to go out and do this
thing and and have an audience that's
more than just you and my parents this
is the first opportunity I have had to
finally live and breathe art rather than
breathing in like leftover
prosciutto-wrapped dates that I stole
from my catering gig they're so good
though yeah I know that's why I
continually take them but I mean then
rats come and I just like haven't
figured out how to it wouldn't be an
issue and you wouldn't have to leave New
York if you just flushed him down the
toilet or wrapped him in tinfoil and
then put him in a five gallon ziplock
it's not about me not knowing how to
flush them it's not about that I mean it
was a teeny bit about like the
methodical strategies in which we have
to avoid rats for the past eight years I
have cleaned out hundreds of people's
pubes out of toilet bowls so many
strangers so many have thrown up on me
you do get thrown up on an exorbitant
amount yeah dude
I am 30 years old I'm done with New York
yeah I get it
I'm really sorry I'm sorry I'm really
I'm gross I made this all about me and
it's not about me but I thought you
would have told me but you know I just
need time I need time to process this I
process the thought of you leaving once
I have that have that for a few months
you know whatever see my therapist
double up for a little while and and
push it through a little bit just a
little time and it'll be okay I'll be
there to support you I promise
so speaking others giving of time
speaking of speaking of time so the
program starts
[Music]
[Applause]
stop
[Music]